[Applause]
a ton of viral moments came from this
year's Golden Globes but the internet is
especially obsessed with a flirty
exchange between Andrew Garfield and
journalist Amelia de moldenberg on the
red carpet I only ever want to see you
what I don't know
I don't ever want to see you in these
kinds of situations what about all the
same situations not interested Amelia is
known for her YouTube series chicken
shop date where she takes various
celebrities for a meal and hilarious
conversation Andrew Garfield has never
made an appearance on the series though
the pair have met on the red carpet
before at the GQ men of the Year Awards
their most recent Golden Globes
interview has captured the attention of
the internet however without thousands
of people begging them to date
I'm an Aquarius
actual mood
if you have a sun sign that's the same
as the moon sign of someone else
it's not good no it's good oh it's good
well it's an issue well because I don't
I don't think we should explore this
okay well I'm not even asking to I know
but I'm just like stay tuned you're a
better thing that's what I'm saying I'm
scared of what it could turn into okay
I'm not ready for that too much I'm not
ready for it oh okay well I am wait
while neither have commented on their
exchange Amelia did tweet out a photo of
their best friend certificate and even
invited Andrew to her upcoming birthday
party